[Music]
my
this fall
six cities
prepare
[Applause]
for two
rebels with a
[Applause]
[Music]
cause phoenix
houston
charleston nashville new york
baltimore
[Applause]
the rebels with a cars comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's june which marks louder with
crowder's seventh annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you
across the globe
learning about and appreciating all the
diverse cultures this planet has to
offer hey you're hankering for a hunk of
heavenly pizza well get a load of my
colossal combo
this week jump in our maserati and take
a ride to the pasta loving culture
that's given us centuries of dazzling
art
[Music]
from the birth of venus to
michelangelo's david's penis
it's the land that puts the ma
in mafia it's italy hey
[Applause]
you guys see that that's a
that's the profile uh welcome glad to be
with you i can't have my headphones on
right now because i can't put it over
the uh the mussolini hat so people
listening on audio this is the uh i of
course
it's cultural appropriation month you
enter in the promo code culture you get
twenty dollars off livewithcrowder.com
mug club and uh you send in your
costumes today for italy we are doing
italy
uh using the hashtag on twitter
instagram lwc italy mussolini um
yeah this won't be taken out of context
no i think you were basically looking up
i'm going to be hanged from there
eventually yes yes
although i was uh transgender
breastfeeding hitler so really this is
child's play at this point that works
and if you've done any research uh and
you guys can comment below how much do
you know about mussolini the history of
mussolini it's hysterical not the not
the death not the genocide all the
horrible but
the fact that they didn't respect him at
all no no no the hitler was just like
yeah put mussolini on it yeah do we have
an intern mussolini my coffee is tepid
so he was aspiring to be an evil
dictator but didn't quite make it uh we
have a lot to talk about today okay uh
jordan peterson dr jordan peterson who's
been on the show has been a good friend
of the show has been banned from twitter
what and he's been corresponding with me
personally and so i have some
information on that and uh look he's
been good to us
uh he's
been an ally to the show he's been he's
been good to you guys it's this is this
is why we fight like hell
this is why we fight like else for
people like him this is not a man who
should be removed from the public sphere
so that's a big deal we'll be talking
about that finland sweden they want to
join nato the former vice president
biden says that's a good idea i say no
why well i have about 550 billion
reasons
that's foreshadowing
uh and then the big hero 6 spin-off is
now transgender buying tampons and
arizona just passed some major school
choice legislation which is a big win so
uh look i i think it's going to be a
good next couple of months all right
gerald a is here the best man the what
are you it's me wario
no you're not you're not i'm wario no
waluigi uh
i didn't know wallowing existed why did
we choose the lesser wa costume yeah the
less amazing i just i'm guessing take
the nose off soon and then you hear him
you know i'm the fastest man uh on his
well on his larger wider feet today
today uh because it is called it's italy
and i'll be on tour with them live north
crowder.com
tour dates
because there are developers on the
website who apparently don't want to
remain gainfully employed the tour
site doesn't work you have to go to tour
dates and uh september 16th the federal
theater september 17th we own in houston
we are kicking off the big fall tour uh
you guys can go to livestream.com tour
dates i'm taking off my hat because i
cannot hear anybody all right dave how
are you i'm good about you
i'm doing i'm doing all right good the
poi leon a horlione
and who who are you wearing holy walnuts
oh
that's right
it could have just been any racist
italian steroids no it's not
it's time for you folks love this of
course coastal appropriation month and
we've been doing this this is our last
week last keep the nose gerald
dave put it in his crotch
uh
it's the price of doing business which
is surprising that he could fit this you
want to work a desk job do you want to
work a desk job i'm at a desk right now
put on the nose
do it it's a little on the nose i went
to a hospital and collected baby
foreskins and made that for you yes
wondering why it was dripping enjoy by
the way you there might be someone
seeking a dna scraping from the preemie
ward
this is my nose now all right so it's
time to play cultural appropriation
month because to appropriate us to
appreciate we learn about these
countries time to play fact or fiction
italy
[Music]
oh we just defended every italian in the
world by calling pizza hut italian well
they should be offended the pizza hut
did it better
oh
oh for a couple years
yeah yeah i'll take crappy pizza please
well look i tell you what when you guys
can settle on who the original ray is in
new york will allow you to have the
better pizza until then americans did it
better all right tokunawan you're going
to read us some facts and we have to
determine if these are real facts about
italy or fiction right that's right okay
so number one is rome is the capital of
italy
gerald oh why you gotta look at me bro i
don't know what i think you feel like
that's a trick question
right i think walnuts i think it's yes i
don't know it feels tricky it feels
tricky uh i'm gonna say yes but i don't
know let's just all say yes sir we're
all in this together yeah just in case
all right i don't know factor fiction
all right that's correct that's fact all
right this seems so obvious
that's why he did it right out of the
outside to make us nervous because we're
going to look like an idiot if we assume
what everybody else assumes yeah or he
was like i'll throw a softball to him
and we're like oh
no it's not
it's venice you mean the city oh it's
beautiful yeah you're you're going that
boat's in sewage
at least
did you know that did you know that it's
sewage they they just dump their poop
yes yes it's poo water but there's a guy
who uh you know takes your throat rolls
you through it yeah
your nose grabs the boats you have a
picnic and if that guy so happens to be
amber heard pooping aft deck so much the
better way he throw it on the bed she
left the grumpy uh all right give us the
next fact here token okay number two the
floccia capozzoli are considered the
most beautiful mountains in italy well
that seems like a subjective fact yeah
well that is true though they are
beautiful i don't know if they're the
most beautiful i think that's a i don't
think those are mountains i'm going
false i'm going to say false just
because i prefer the uh what do you have
listed you have the uh fellowship
capazelli see i'm uh felocia capistrano
guy i think those are the prettier
mountains i'm gonna go true all right
together all right that is fiction yeah
ah fiction because they're not real
mountains what does it mean
i just google it
that means he doesn't know that means
these are half-assed fact or fiction no
no i think you can't say is that this is
that
yeah i know what it means in fact i
think that it's a fact yeah
like fact or fiction do you think monica
baluchi is hot fact yeah yeah fact
that who's that monica blue you're gay
so there's a lot of people at work right
now very very obsessed that means she's
gay
do you seriously don't know who monica
bellucci is no all right we'll bring up
a picture of her later
beautiful woman isabella rosalini's are
beautiful there are a lot of
good-looking italian ladies monica
what is it well the reason she's a
marvel because she's in a good-looking
older italian woman whereas like italian
women reach their prime at like 19 and
then leave it at 22. yeah they age like
cottage cheese now uh the next fact
all right next up we got number three
over 400 italians die each year in hand
gesture related accidents that is
absolutely true what that is got to be
true yeah i mean he took out one of the
intern's eyes earlier that's got to be
true true
okay and the answer is that is fiction
though you're fiction
you're fiction we're the nose you're
fiction liar yeah that's true you're
fiction without the science the little
whatever soul ron centurion
show the next one okay number four every
october vatican city holds a kind of
city hawkins dance where the altar boys
ask out the priests
that's true
i've been to it yeah
well he was actually the chaperone yes
oh geez
it's named after you didn't have to i'm
going to say of course that is fiction
fiction true
i mean
it's true
what yeah kind of i'm sorry what look it
ain't so much a dance but it is a dance
of the body okay hold on no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
you got it it's nature's dance of
seduction that's about to say the the
priests don't tend to ask the altar boys
their opinion no they don't situation
it's fiction okay all right all right
next one we got is the pope mobile is
bulletproof and has a turret that shoots
bean bag rounds
100 true i hope that's true i guarantee
i know it's bulletproof i don't know
about the bean bag rounds i'd be willing
to bet my desk that technically is your
desk that it's true yes say full it's
not technically my desk it is my desk
well technically all of these are my
desks technically speaking true and
false so false
okay i'm gonna say true
okay that is fiction
oh no he went with the flamethrower it's
a flamethrower isn't it there there's
just isn't anything mounted you're right
it is bulletproof but there's no turret
there has to be a turret
that would be so much
sooner or later that pacifist will have
to pay am i right yeah by the way you
can have the desk sorry i bet to bet
yeah
great
betting with the house's money thank you
waluigi yeah yeah thank you
that's how we do it stephen come on
it's like it's like my brother and i
would steal my pogs and then play for
keeps i'm like wait hold on a second
this is gargle pogba i thought these
were mine all right
last fact all right final one for all
the marbles 53 of tuscany residents work
in the parmesan mines
i'm not going to lie i don't even know
that parmesan mines are a thing they're
not oh yeah it's not true at all
yeah they're real i go true there's a
fat and by the way those canaries they
come out fat yeah they do
yeah in
canary love to eat the cheese you heard
of the canary in the coal mine you know
they send it in
there's come out with gout that's true
these are the cannoli mines that they
work
only that's a whole different thing
that's a whole different thing that's
really just a reverse sex change
operation big wilford brimley bays
they're all ornery yeah
they're very short with their families
give us the truth or fiction all right
that is
fiction of course it is
mindful parmesan that's been italy facts
good things
no they're not a lot of good things
i feel like i learned nothing
i used to call my girl this the pizza
[ __ ]
really yeah from you meet her at pizza
hut that's right oh that's a good thing
my pockets are just not they're not you
know when your pockets aren't tucked in
right yeah it bothers me it does it was
an inverted pocket which by the way
we're going to get to why jordan
peterson was banned regarding
later
uh let's first do this i was instructed
not to watch this
not to watch this okay uh
this is a commercial in europe
and all i know is have you guys seen
this no no uh now first off let me be
really clear this is where i part ways
with the identitarian right because i go
we need a western european nation well
the problem is that western european
nations suck right they're terrible
they're they're they're godless
devoid of morals just crap holes at this
point if you were talking about
something basically what you're talking
about is what the united states
originally was fine i get that i don't
want to be like italy i don't want to be
like france no i don't want to be like
england i don't want to be
any of the norwegian countries which by
the way they're having a competition to
see with finland sweden and norway who
is the most irrelevant country
they're all winners it is such a close
race yeah yeah it's a photo finish
but this is a commercial in europe and
all i've been told is that it's full of
surprises dear god
[Music]
normal so far
[Music]
it's a one-night roll
you can't beat up a crippled man
i'm sure you can
we tell that's very easy how do they do
anything
all right what what the we're pausing it
oh okay why
well that that's the end of the clip
because you have to guess what happens
next what what what is it advertising oh
what is it advertising so let's see it
was a one-night stand it's obviously
some kind of norwegian norwegian i don't
know if it's swedish i have no idea
nordic yeah yeah but did i say norwegian
one of those you know weird language no
one cares about these countries thursday
you guys have contributed nothing and by
the way you're not welcome to be
protected by nato i.e the united states
play your tab
she runs she's doing it with a crippled
guy and then it looks like her husband
comes in yeah yeah so what is it is it
like for ball bearing grease for his
wheelchair i think he's late because his
flight was delayed or something and it's
a travel well i hope she's not late from
a crippled guy well she couldn't no
maybe it's for viagra because you know
he can't feel nothing right oh it could
be for colostomy bags yeah that's
unlikely you know what that's all good
ideas i'm gonna go with ring doorbell
show me what it is
all right here it is
[Music]
it's a psa for not parking in a disabled
spot wow if you park in my spot it's
like banging my wife well banging your
wife oh no that's what i'm saying yeah
that's what it's what that's the
comparison
but you you physically can on account of
your you know that would just be i feel
like hair releases maybe like tuning in
today you just tuned into nickelodeon
and it's just images of auschwitz and
warsaw and genocide i was like pick up
after your dog
now you know what it feels like what is
it such a problem there that they had to
make this commercial well maybe you know
i just i'm amazed at that well okay
great is there an outrage from the
disabled community over that i don't
know i wouldn't think that they all want
to be labeled uh men who sleep with
other men's wives well it's it's
theoretical yeah hypothetical i mean you
know maybe they're you eliminate from
the pool there many of them the bottom
half doesn't work
that's true it was the mercy lay yeah
your husband parked in my spot why do
you know where i live yeah this is weird
i watch you a lot i cross reference your
license plate in my spot yes i've been
watching you from the rear window yes
also go check on the children i've
poisoned them yes oh that'll remind you
to use your turn signal this has just
gone way too far for a psa this is over
the top that is too much and don't do
drugs it's not a handicap spot it's next
to one yeah oh my bad it's an expectant
mother spot i'm one of those two yes how
is that possible you're not a veteran do
you know what country this is
yeah your main claim to fame is that
you've remained neutral until you now
want to be in nato it protected and the
answer is no all right let's go to this
this is something that is really
important i don't know how many people
discuss it but i'm
sorry i have some exclusive information
here some inside baseball please just
look comment below to show jordan
peterson your support
if you're watching this on on youtube
and also hit the like button because we
want to get this message out to as many
people as possible dr jordan peterson
uh suspended
last night on twitter
now just to be clear twitter is the
story you're going to hear is well he's
only temporarily just temporarily
suspended if he takes down the tweet
yeah with controversy so that's what
they say well you could get your account
back
just like the new york post could get
their account back if they remove the
hunter biden story yeah exactly so
that's what they'll try and claim and
say oh free speech doesn't mean you can
say whatever plus his account wasn't
banned it's effectively banned if you
express an opinion
that they don't like and by the way in
this instance it's an opinion that is
completely in line with the scientific
community and biological literature that
we have had since the beginning of
ever
ever or between mostly ever take your
pick yeah it was a benign tweet we'll
get to it in a minute but
his uh his daughter michaela announced
that uh while uh jordan peterson got a
twitter strike no more twitter until he
deletes the tweet
definitely so okay
she mentioned that but uh you know we
can amplify this a little bit more
here's the tweet that got him
removed you won't be able to see it now
uh i don't believe that you can because
of the way his account is disabled but
we do have a screen grab from the tweet
that got him removed it was a tweet
regarding ellen page remember when pride
was a sin and ellen page just had her
breasts removed by a criminal physician
that's that seems pretty benign that's
well he said a criminal physician now
let me be clear let me give you some
context here you know i don't know if
you know ellen page who's now elliot
page here are some pictures of uh elliot
page today
um yeah on the cover of esquire hey and
they wonder why men aren't buying their
subscriptions anymore wait a second uh i
i i i used to read gentlemen's quarterly
is the picture behind that not a man
i enjoy the bulge and sports illustrated
swimsuit edition yes oh yeah exactly i
love it well that's just because they're
italian women they haven't been
familiarized with venus yeah no it's uh
so that's elliot page uh ellen page for
those who are the uninitiated because
they've retroactively gone back and
applied elliott page to the imdb credits
so again it's never a consistent
standard did caitlyn jenner win a medal
then why does elliot page get acting
credits is that his boyfriend in that
photo i believe that is his boyfriend
just want to make sure yeah his
boyfriend and i
okay there's so we're going to get some
statistics here as to why it's actual
medical malpractice and this is a
criminal physician look i'll say it
what's the hippocratic oath at first do
no harm yeah okay so dr jordan peterson
is pointing out
something
that would be harmful that's why he's
using the term criminal physician
because there's a level of criminality
you used to be charged if you were a
doctor who did something who performed a
procedure that knowingly caused harm and
this was important because long after
science was established whether it would
be things like mercury fillings or
lobotomies right they found out that
doctors were performing them after they
were no longer legally allowed to
perform them and so these people had to
be brought up on charges so that there
were consequences why because you are
putting some of your trust into the
medical institution when you go and see
a doctor it's like going to a mechanic
you don't really know what he's saying
you just kind of take his word for it he
says it looks like the transistor
uh a flam is is gone all right here's
three thousand dollars i hope you're not
screwing me usually he is
but look at look at what the tweet says
it didn't call for any action against
the physician right obviously twitter
has their standards that they they say
they operate by we know that they don't
didn't call for violence on anybody
didn't make fun of anybody didn't say
anything about the doctor's name didn't
dox anybody i don't understand where
they're coming from legally with giving
him any kind of punishment at all and by
the way just to be clear he's also not
saying remember when pride was a sin
meaning homosexual pride month what he's
saying is
showing pictures off of your naked torso
and telling everybody else demanding
that they declare you beautiful that was
something that people said was it look
come on look if a guy were to if a
non-trans guy would do that like douche
douche every uh you don't want to talk
to elliot uh he's a douche why every
single pictures of his abs are grabbing
his balls like that's just that's a guy
who's just that's a douche baber oh
sorry chas bono douche why a guy with a
chin strap beard just wants to take his
shirt off every time wear a tank top
it's just a douche
it's the same thing with many men who
act like women who are trans women all
of a sudden we're okay with a man
fulfilling the negative barbie
stereotype of womanhood that we've been
trying to break down with feminism for
it but when it's a transgender
individual oh brave and beautiful
because you can't define woman
what's a trans man going to be a
masculine woman no they have to put on
i'm a woman why because i put on makeup
and i use tampons and look i like to
look pretty and i like to wear dresses
hold on a second we were told those were
negative stereotypes just look at the
lesbians and jeans and tank tops yeah
so
it's first do no harm are these criminal
physicians well let me give you a little
bit of info here all references are
available at earthquake.com okay
particularly with women
becoming
men or wanting to become men what do
they have to do they have to go through
hormone replacement therapy we've talked
uh before about estradiol estrogen when
you give it to men we know that
increases risks of cancer we know that
even with women it increases risks of
cancer but testosterone specifically in
women increased testosterone
testosterone replacement therapy
it's linked to increase of all kind of
metabolic disorders cancer and this is
something really interesting
testosterone increases metabolic
diseases like type 2 diabetes in women
but increased testosterone men reduces
it it's almost like
we're different no
hey now we're on 18. make sure you're
watching on rumble yeah
exactly by the way we're on rumble
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
and of course on mug club we are going
to be on break there will be some super
videos uploaded but we are back the very
first monday of august
uh with a new uh new new space here new
studio uh marone so think about this for
a second think of that if you don't
believe there's a design
well you have a very limited window of
where hormones are appropriate and they
are uh allotted in certain amounts in
the male body and the female body if you
increase testosterone you have a higher
natural end of testosterone in men that
decreases your likelihood of type 2
diabetes metabolic disorders also you
might say well that's because higher
testosterone is linked to fat loss but
the same would apply to women right if
it's just a fat loss mechanism
but they're still at higher risk of
diabetes
which just tells you there is something
that we don't fully understand
right the science is out but the science
that we have that is in is pretty bad
that the female body says ah i'm not
supposed to have that much of what of
the man stuff
oh we have to get rid of it somehow i
don't know spike insulin cause acne uh
infertility let's just just ah
it's like you're on fire doing damage to
the body because you're putting it in an
unnatural state where are all the
homeopathic doctors who don't believe in
the big pharmaceutical company who want
to chew kushtonga root where are this is
by the way let me let me be clear about
this i'm going to get to the cancer uh
stats in a second this is from the
largest study to date okay
so you're going to see an overlay
reference lateralcredit.com from the
largest study to date uh on sex hormone
levels
gene regulation this is from the
university of cambridge
and uh is it pronounced exeter exester
yeah exeter
they also found that higher testosterone
levels increase the risks of breast and
endometriosis cancers in women
okay that's not enough to say well you
know what a criminal physician well
here's the thing uh we have some more
receipts there are other health risks
and complications that would be
associated with other things like
elliott page so elliot page just doing
the testosterone just doing the hormones
yeah those are those risks but then
eliot page formerly ellen page
also got a double mastectomy
some risks with that include blood clots
bleeding infection nerve nerve pain
heart attack stroke kidney failure
pneumonia
now
if we go down to the so we have the
cancer risk with the metabolic risk from
the hormones and now we have the risk
just from the procedure of a double
mastectomy which by the way it's not as
high as the hormones and not as high as
the
you know the fake penis surgery which
we'll get to in a second yeah um
but it's an entirely elective procedure
just to be clear
there's no reason for a doctor to
provide that if there is no immediate
health requirement and there isn't
beyond i really don't like my tits yeah
and they want us to be able to have to
pay for that as taxes yes citizens yes
not only for our military because we've
had people get that before chelsea
manning i believe was one of those uh
but everybody else that you have to be a
part of the program to remove your
children from you if you don't allow
them to go through it so we've got the
risks with the hormones we've got the
risks with the double mastectomy
again does it does it hold water jordan
peterson the reason he was banned saying
criminal physician
first do no harm
hear the health risks the complications
that are
associated with with phthaloplasty and
yes that's exactly what you think
for trans patients so let's go through
the percentages of these risks happening
okay getting a fake big old fight penis
big old fake penis what we used to refer
to as medically necessary i'd like the
jumbo please so here it's uh
yeah can you imagine that on his frame
yeah yeah
it would leave trails in the snow like a
basset hound had a lot of donkeys
because it's four inches yes
oh was that medically necessary
absolutely yeah yeah if i didn't do if i
don't get a fake penis my family will
die oh i have an erection and there's a
blood clot can you uh go ahead and touch
my bracelets yes
wait which one the life alert no my
lucky charm bracelet yeah it's just
neither really will work at this point
they stopped answering at life alert i
decided to be a white guy in 2022.
that's a good move
[Laughter]
so let me go through the phalloplasty
risks okay hair stone formation in the
urethra five percent risk infections a
14 risk which by the way requires a
removal in most cases of the prosthetic
yeah uh partial skin flap loss a 12.9
percent risk what is that do you know
what skin flap loss we're going to show
the pictures on the club later okay just
use your imagination okay
just my murder and uh
by the way the death the loss of those
uh sections of the skin uh used these
are being used to make that it's just
disgusting okay urethral blockage we're
now at 24
24 of people who go through these
surgeries experience urethral blockage
this other term i want to make sure to
read this correctly and the stat is
staggering
you urethral cutaneous fistula
and that's where
urine is leaking from new holes or wrong
holes
49.5
in other words there's a one in two
chance that if you get a fake penis
you'll be pissing like the gremlin who
was shot at the food bar yeah
you imagine pitching this in a meeting
like a car company like is it safe no
no it's not well there's a 49.5 percent
chance you'll pee from your balls but
hey like one in two people are gonna
have real problems right yeah where are
all these consumer reporters by the way
consumer reporters who complain about
you know uh problems with the uh the the
the prius and by the way i was happy to
see any damage done with the prius but
it's a terrible looking car it's just
awful and everyone who can't drive got
together had a secret meeting and said
prius are we good we'll all drive that
yeah good by the way turn signals are
right out
no need to have one
but where are all these consumer
reporters this company man they're
taking it look this could cause harm or
tap water in flint and i'm not saying
that these are illegitimate grievances
but we're always where there's a 50 risk
that you pee out of the wrong hole
there's a 25 percent chance of urethral
blockage there's a multiple
increase in likelihood of cancers of
metabolic disorders that occur nowhere
else in nature and instead you ban dr
jordan peterson for saying
that this is medically wrong
up until very recently
the medical community all of them said
it was medically wrong and you know what
happens when the remainder of the
medical community says it's wrong like
johns hopkins
you're gone you're no longer allowed or
they revoke your license why don't you
trust your institutions i don't know why
don't we trust the medical institutions
maybe because you just force-fed people
vaccinations
right now you're trying to do it for
kids at six months old and at the very
least what you promised is not what
people got right as far as the immunity
i'm not even going to get into the idea
of the side effects which we've covered
you can just run a search here on
youtube or probably on mug club because
you won't find it
on youtube if you type in vaccination
side effects it will be did you mean
that you want to report misinformation
insinuating that there are side effects
no that's not what i meant do we know
what he's going to do about this has he
indicated he's not removing the tweet
right he has told me he is not removing
the tweet standing is going so you guys
can support jordan peterson i think he's
still on youtube uh i don't know if he's
on instagram i believe he
is the announcement out that he just
that he's doing something with
daily i don't know okay
i want to be careful at this time i
don't know but there are a lot of places
to support him and to follow him and i
recommend that you do and you know what
good for him he shouldn't take this down
that is a criminal physician and uh i do
believe that you are violating the
hippocratic oath if you are knowingly
performing a surgery on someone that
will put them into a cancerous
shallow grave and i only say shallow
because elliott page is very slight he's
very very slight so
here's something maybe people can do
send out two tweets if you're on twitter
right now go to twitter and tweet this
out to at elon musk right letting elon
musk know this is kind of a fun thing to
do i'm not sure if he can do anything
necessarily about it but then also your
senator let your senator know so there
is the possibility that when things like
this happen like when what happened with
the uh the article from the new york
post ted cruz was asking that question
of that why did you do this right so may
not happen right now but at least bring
it to their attention so go do that
right now and just see if you can get as
many eyeballs on this as possible
because that's not free speech that's
one of the most benign tweets i've seen
i cannot believe that they were like oh
that's hate speech how in the world oh i
absolutely can i can't i don't see it
did you forget that our that one of our
youtube videos was removed when a
transgender threw a homeless man's lunch
box at me and i laughed it's because of
the laughing and they said that by me
laughing and by the way you can go and
watch this on mug club if you're not a
member there's a section with all the
banned videos this person came up tried
to assault me and then stole a box from
a homeless man yeah threw it at me and
ran away with his high heels clipping
and i laughed and they and youtube said
that was denying
his existence her existence sorry it is
men i was laughing at a poor throw yes
it was laughing at a poor throw and then
the clapping and the fact that this
person is such an awful bag of [ __ ] that
they what they were throwing was stolen
from a homeless person it's on camera
and you can go see it it's been banned
it's on mudclub yes so i can imagine i
can absolutely believe that jordan
peterson was banned from twitter for
that kind of there's no way to hide on
this one there's no way to hide they're
going to have to reinstate him yeah well
maybe we'll have him here on the show
here next well no not here next week but
we'll have him on the show maybe i'll do
maybe i'll do a long-form thing we just
upload during the break we pre-tape with
a zoom it's simple get it up because my
god i mean my my heart i don't see my
heart breaks for the guy he'll be fine
this is not an issue that should be
happening in the united states of
america not at all no more draw your
line that's it that's it
i'm done with this is he what is he in
the u.s or canada
uh i don't
i don't know that i'm alone i don't know
i don't know where he lives full-time
but he splits this guy an undisclosed
location i know it's undisclosed yes
he's in actually the cave with all the
facets of all variables oh there's it's
like whoa man so it's an empty cave i
just think you're allowed to have these
opinions especially when they're backed
with facts if he was batman alfred would
be like oh shut up
please go do some stuff that's dangerous
yeah
you know what's most dangerous oh geez
it's honesty oh all right no
what's more dangerous is bane's super
weapon okay go fight that oh it's more
dangerous sleeping on thread sheet count
uh 300 uh that's that's nice yeah no
that's ben shapiro no no he could do a
pretty good segue too that's incredibly
dangerous sleeping on 230 calories i use
ball and french bed sheet she like son
of a [ __ ] he just put an ad in there
again again and i didn't even know
defending jordan but look at these
surgeries all the references are
available at lighthousecrowd.com and
we're not linking we're not linking to
fox news we're linking to published
medical journals in this case the
largest study that has been conducted on
this kind of a transitional operation
hormones right there are several
different studies that we've had to
compile you can go and check those
references i encourage that you do
that's why we make them available
i want you to know the truth do not take
my word for it and if i'm wrong comment
below and let me know and can you
imagine though that being said the kind
of pr prep work that a surgery like that
would take oh right imagine being the
guy in charge of shaving
this his patience right and that's
what's um what's going on uh what's
going on out there oh i gotta go take
care of something oh jeez okay
uh is this you're just gonna go yeah
okay well we need to take care of what's
going on out there all right
[Music]
get a men's shave here in the public
bathroom
15 claims get shaved in the bathroom who
wants a nice shave hey
you shaving faces over there no i didn't
like that
you giving haircuts nah you need a
license for them all right then what are
you doing i shave uh body hair
body hair you even around the old
meatballs and gravity goat the what you
know
the laffatelli the french vanilli
the vinedicci oh i know what you're
saying yeah especially around them
that's why i got the manscape lawnmower
4.0 it's got a skin safety shield it
does the best job you'll ever see that
i've ever seen
forget about it come with me in a men's
bathroom and we'll do stuff do stuff
yeah
[Music]
that's why that bathroom hasn't been
available for the last hey the last
while uh and i should tell you guys by
the way they respond to the show
wonderful and uh we have very few
sponsors if you notice we usually do mug
club but manscaped go to manscape.com
use the promo code crowder20 and you get
20 off with free shipping i will tell
you this okay
um
i just said okay it's another trimmer
the light makes a big difference game
changer the light is a game changer and
i don't look i don't know if other there
are other companies that have a light
but my trimmers before this did not have
a light
i wish i had one with a light for my
face but i can't use the same one that
you know i've used on my balls you can't
no you so men out there i used to use
one tape to my rifle yes
because when you cut down there that
hurts yeah no the light makes a big
difference it's unflattering it's
unflattering you know if you have bumps
you will see them
the freshly shown you will be like what
is what is going on i didn't know that i
had a braille taint yeah it really
i didn't want to give it that so you can
replace those divots
no you cannot
there's ain't no caddyshack two bumpy
fairways or not jackie mason uh so
crowder 20 20 off uh free shipping at
manscapes.com and of course it's a great
gift if you have someone you know fourth
of july if you get fourth of july gifts
i don't really know but right now i
guess something is breaking here uh the
supreme court as we are live it is 10 50
eastern yeah supreme court watch gerald
uh you were letting me know about this
yeah absolutely so the supreme court was
ruling on something that impacted the
power of the epa so in west virginia
versus epa scotus ruled six three can i
pause you really quickly yes yes i hate
the epa well this is going to make you
smile oh good okay so in in a 6-3 ruling
scotus rule that the epa does not have
the authority to set national energy
policies so this is basically from my
understanding is that the epa's kind of
control was getting out of hand their
power
was not well i will say this i'm glad at
the decision but if the epa doesn't
control national energy policy well what
do they do
well they're just supposed to i guess
they're supposed to limit like polluting
oh yes okay maybe stick with what the
the agenda should have been from the
beginning so this will greatly curtail
their ability to regulate greenhouse gas
emissions that's one of the things and
this could also inhibit the ability of
other government agencies this is the
big one to regulate industry that power
was never given to government agencies
right it was given to congress and
in some cases well and grethenberg so
you're a child at the time and the the
court ruled 5 4 in favor of biden
administration in its case against the
state of texas the this is not great
news but the administration can rescind
that remain in mexico policy that was uh
made famous under donald trump well
let's focus on the epa that's a good one
yeah so those were the decisions but the
epa so this is this is big because they
were basically making the epa their
henchmen you know they're sticking with
the italian theme here right they just
come by and be like it'd be a shame if
you got closed down for pollution right
you know that's the kind of stuff that
was really kind of going on with the epa
they really were acting like the mob in
something it wasn't the epa that screwed
up the colorado river not that long ago
well they did they do a lot of they do a
lot of screwing up just because they're
bad at their job here's the issue right
when you're dealing with the epa first
off you have to believe let's go through
this right the
i don't want to say the intellectual
fallacies but here you can just hit a
ding as i go through these so people can
kind of okay you have to go through a
few
different sets of beliefs to be upset
with this decision all right
you have to believe that climate change
not global warming that climate change
is real number one okay you have to
believe that human beings are the
primary cause of it number two okay you
have to believe that it is going to have
catastrophic results imminently number
three okay and you have to believe that
we are capable of actually stopping
nature's course
and preventing those catastrophic
results number four
you then have to believe that the only
people who are capable of stopping said
imminent disasters that are being caused
by human beings about which there can be
no disagreement is the government number
five
and then you have to believe of all the
government agencies that uh the most
efficient and effective is of course the
epa number six so if you're mad with
this then that means do you believe all
six of those
right because don't call me a climate
denier because i say you know what maybe
it's a little toasty but uh
i think grantham is full of [ __ ] by the
way what's the over under that al gore
is hanging from a massage chair with a
windsor knot no he's flying around in
his private jet contributing to said
global warming which he said probably
would destroy the planet by now i
believe unless they say well it's all
right to leave a giant carbon footprint
as long as you're also helping the
environment ah can i have a point how
else will al gore and john kerry sky
drag race
point number seven you also have to
believe that aoc in her little five page
document is at the ready to solve the
problem
green new deal baby yeah
five pages
was this written on construction paper
yes yes it was is this an executive
summary nope the entire thing hey by the
way by the way researchers maybe you
guys can search for for this here real
quick uh and you guys can let me know
comment below before i go on the finland
and nato
aoc you know she was speaking there in
uh uh was it uh
tompkins square was it washington square
park
and she just dropped the bomb or she
said you know she was raped
yes she said i was she's and keep in
mind her wording
was very very careful she said
working here you know as a waitress i
had friends who had to walk home alone
at night they were raped i was raped as
a young woman so it's like hold on a
second are you saying that you were
walking home alone and you were raped no
she separated that which to me was
concerning has she been on record
discussing being raped before this
because i had not seen and she said i
was so alone that i had to take a
pregnancy test in a new york city public
bathroom why didn't you go home
why don't you just go home to take the
pregnancy test i don't i don't know
there's so many things that don't add up
there i'm just wanting hey can we was
there a police report filed
wait she took the pregnancy test the
same night you know well i don't know
she just said she had to do it in a
public bathroom like i guess maybe the
rapist was still following her and like
you know you can only take that test
at the dwayne reed restroom well here's
a key with a nunchuck on it yeah
well if there's anywhere i guess
that ray victor would want to go it's an
enclosed public space right
that doesn't make as opposed to the
private room in the city where you live
right that like oh hey maybe i should
carry out this very private procedure
clearly in the privacy of my home
clearly it's not a lie because aoc said
it well i would say this if she would
say she almost died it's a tragedy we
all of course if she was written
but she's an opportunist
no here's what is there a police report
yeah no because guess what guess what i
don't know if you're going if if if you
were raped first off i want to know did
she go out and tell the story anywhere
else i know she said she was afraid that
she was going to be raped on january 6th
officers saving her life yeah
um i know she claimed she was afraid of
that but i i don't know that there's a
track record again i'm just looking for
you guys to comment below i've tried to
i haven't found it and certainly not
with this kind of detail taking a
pregnancy test in a new york city
bathroom here's something else i would
like to see if she was which is horrible
and you didn't file a police report
how about you encourage women to file
police reports yeah
how about if you want to talk about
destigmatizing it right women should all
come forward and file these police
reports and take these rape kits because
i think that men who actually commit
forcible rape should be buried
next to the prison okay
there you go but we need
we need to know
can anyone find was there a police
report back then if not okay how long
has she been telling us this story
something doesn't pass the sniff test
and i hope to god that it didn't happen
yeah i hope to god that she was never
rigged if she was raped
that's terrible yeah and i hope that's
not oh we went out and had too many
drinks and i regretted having sex with
this person the next day that's that's
that's not rape well i did the legwork
after elena dunham claimed it found the
guy and it turned out it wasn't true and
then she walked it back afterwards so
i'm just always a little bit concerned
when someone drops it at some kind of a
rally and this is not something where
there's a track record there's no police
report
you know what i think that kind of
matters i think it absolutely matters i
think there needs to be due process and
i want to see rapists prosecuted you
can't complain about how men are not
brought to justice and then not do your
part to bring them to justice you're the
only one who can do that part no one
else can do that part women if it's
happened to you
please
please come forward go to the police
do the rape
use these rape kits that are available
try and if it happens god forbid first
off i hope that you're armed and you can
protect yourself there's another fail
safe right before that try and avoid
situations where you might find yourself
vulnerable i'm not saying wear the wrong
dress what i'm saying is don't go out
alone at night don't go to areas of town
where there's a lot of violent crime
keep your head in a swivel use the buddy
system be armed if you're in a city that
does not allow you to be armed leave
said city immediately and then if you do
find yourself in that scenario god
forbid keep your head in a swivel
take some memory triggers mental notes
so that you can go to the police and put
that man behind bars for the rest of his
life
okay absolutely that's what i want to
see well
uh statistically most women who are
brutally raped if they know who the
perpetrator was do go to the police
right
especially if it's violent right yeah do
right away that's an important point
because the left says the opposite well
you just you brought up something too
aoc shouldn't she be celebrating the
ruling for new york city or the state of
new york actually not being able to
limit who can get a concealed carry
wouldn't your friends like to have had a
handgun in their purse walking down that
dark alley late at night after one of
their shifts
should you guys be all like cheering
this decision so you can finally protect
yourself oh situation last night they
shot uh somebody in the upper upper east
side yeah by the way they have not named
the race of the perpetrator no but don't
worry he was wearing all black
hmm
yeah so that's good yeah that'll help
narrow it down yeah and
19 years old 20 years old or whatever
they still couldn't figure out that you
know the poor woman's age was pushing a
stroller right and then the the mayor
takes it to the first opportunity
to say this is the problem with bringing
guns into the city it's like do you
think that was a registered firearm
right yeah like you think that's the
like it was what a card-carrying member
of the nra yes that went up and shot her
execution style in the upper east side
and do you know how i know it was not
because the law doesn't exist yet right
so it was guaranteed an illegal firearm
right even obviously we would know that
regardless right but that being said we
know it without a doubt because there's
sure it certainly hasn't just gone into
effect we're like oh man this is this is
great now starting this second i can go
and shoot old ladies that's you know i'm
an originalist and interpreting the law
right just it's astonishing that it
would just come out it's like how stupid
are you yeah and do we want to place any
bets
on
who the perpetrator might have been well
he did say this is mega country oh he
did oh yeah did he do he said that
before using a noose and pouring bleach
yeah i think that happened and they said
he was wearing um all that color it
wasn't
close no he was actually just wearing a
see-through mesh shirt
[Laughter]
unbelievable i had a three-month-old
baby in the stroller it's disgusting
that's that's awful why now is it so
important like i don't know what he was
honestly but it's like okay it's like
there's an amber alert
and you go the car was uh it was an
automobile and it had four wheels yes
oh well that's we believe an engine of
some kind yeah well we're not sure it
remains to be seen it's definitely
moving the steering wheel that was
actually
trump tried to grab this steering wheel
too whereas you could have just said uh
yeah he was driving an el camino with
lifts we'll let you draw your own
conclusions someone's like found him
right
are you what about the license plate and
you're like listen
it's more important to be woke now
than to save the life of people on the
street yeah well where's the hierarchy
there of women women being targeted
right like we talked about with asian
americans it's just the left just uses
you when you are convenient for them so
we don't have any info on this no i'm
willing to bet willing to bet that it
wasn't a republican
racist white supremacist in new york
city with a registered firearm who shot
a 90-something-year-old lady and by the
way the extreme the extreme extreme is
no one should have a gun right that's
the extreme my right you're left i'm
trying to do this for you the other
extreme and i mean really extreme and
i'm not saying i would line up with this
is that that baby should have a gun but
i would lean toward that
yeah when you said 90 something year old
she was 20 the the lady who the lady was
20 19 yeah
was she 20 officials i saw 20 but okay
they were going back and forth
originally it was reported she was an
old lady
no it was 19. oh wait sorry i'm mixing
up two corrections yeah yeah yeah it's
probably an incident it's tough to find
them in new york these days yeah oh no
same night don't yeah i'm sure it was
the same block
and the upper east side i mean that's a
nice area or was yeah i lived there in
yorkville for uh about nine months yeah
off of 77th and uh between second and
first yeah i mean it's it's a nice area
yeah i had a studio where if i trip in
the kitchen i hit my head in the
bathroom yeah that's well that's so
that's what i loved i had one in harlem
wait i just peed in this which wasn't a
bad area when i lived there even three
years ago and then all of a sudden
boy yeah that's all of new york all
right let's go to something here that is
near and dear to my heart and by that i
mean seething hatred
so finland and sweden now
they want and we just got word from uh
former vice president biden uh
celebrating this they want to join nato
okay
i want you to comment below before i
give you some numbers that might shock
you
but all right i'm going to lead the
witness here
no
now
let's tell you how we go let me tell you
how i got there
you might be wondering how i got here um
also what's really important to note
maybe people don't understand they don't
think of this because we often just
think of the welfare state we think of
that as a just redistribution of wealth
the international military community and
nato and un that is an international
redistribution of wealth always at the
cost of the american taxpayer not at the
cost of the swedish taxpayer not at the
cost of the german taxpayer when you're
talking about international agreements
the numbers are not even close
it's
thank you united states for allowing us
to tag along and not making us states 50
through 90 at this point you think
attila the hun you think genghis khan
you think the ottomans would allow
canada or even europe to exist if they
had planes
so
tuesday and then we have biden talking
this morning nato's uh secretary general
announced that finland and sweden were
one step closer after turkey dropped its
objections and so this started the
chatter of should they be able to join
here's the nato secretary general who i
believe is norwegian but talking about
finland and sweden it's easy to get
mixed up again because these countries
are inconsequential in the general
history of the world
we've just
finished a very constructive meeting
with president alderweireld
president ninisto and prime minister
anderson that sounds like he just
mumbled the name because he couldn't say
it
announce that we now have an agreement
that paves the way for finland and
sweden
to join nato
yeah um i want that way paved with walls
and moats yes and gold it's not so much
a paving as it is a renovation project
no
you don't get to join well you get to
join nato under some very specific terms
just to be clear and i'll lay out what
those terms are um uh hint they can't
meet them
uh biden former vice president biden of
course was celebrating the move this
morning in madrid invited two new
members to join nato
it was a historic act
finland and sweden
two countries with a long tradition of
neutrality
and choosing to join nato
okay no no no no no no no no no no
gerald give it just let me go here
really quickly i probably know more
about nato than you because i hate the
things
nato 1949 here's basically what it is
okay without getting into complicating
the issue after world war ii after we
had this struggle right people were
concerned about the soviets okay it's an
international military agreement what
does that mean you join up two percent
of your gdp annually is put into nato uh
nato funding which is basically nato
military spending at that point it was
supposed to be a military alliance
that benefited everybody we protected
each other right so it was if you pay
this in
right this is an installment plan here
you pay and you get to be a part of the
drawing pool if it needs to be used
okay there were a set number of nations
who joined sweden and finland
being pompous [ __ ] and having
bragged about being neutral for the last
several decades decided no
well guess what you get to be neutral
because we allow you to be and we
protect you so that you can claim to be
neutral you're in sweden you're a nation
that's given us nothing but birth
control and gummy fish okay nothing
nothing a couple of chefs that's it okay
so let's go through the number
historically the united states has paid
13.5 trillion
13.5 trillion with a t into nato in 2021
the united states spent more than 811
billion dollars on nato funding that's
3.5 percent of the gdp by the way before
we get to finland and sweden we should
boot the countries that aren't paying
two percent of their gdp and by the way
that's a lot of them
okay that's a lot of them so now sweden
having not paid
into nato for all of these years going
like oh things looking like they could
get rough we need protection yeah well
you know how we didn't pay at all and we
bragged about how you guys were paying
in the military industrial complex and
we have all this uh socialized health
care yeah now we now we want in no
nope you got a lot of back pay
a lot of back pay
so two percent is what the agreement is
at least in in 2006 it was different
before that okay so it's tough to do
some numbers because you're talking
about the history of nato modern inflat
inflation modern dollars but in twenty
twenty dollars two percent of gdp for
sweden would be ten point eight billion
dollars a year finland that would be
five point three billion dollars a year
so let's just lower that contribution to
one point five percent adjust the
dollars to gdp for uh 1960 because 49 to
today right it wouldn't be fair to use
the numbers for today because of
inflation so we'll just split the middle
say 1960 adjust for inflation this is
the back pay it would be 153 billion
dollars for sweden would be 50 billion
dollars for finland and that would be
extremely generous to them going back to
1960 in today's dollars right using
their present gdps sweden would owe 592
billion dollars in back pay finland
would owe 295 billion dollars in back
pay so how about this look once you pay
your let's split the difference 250
billion dollars each in back pay you
know the money that you didn't pay in
well we were protecting your sorry ass
and you bragged about all of your social
programs that you couldn't afford if you
had to spend anything on your military
you pay the back pay you walk out
get on your knees and apologize and you
allow us to paddle you
fair
and then two percent every and just
because you didn't do it for a long time
you know what the united states has paid
3.5 you got to pay two and a half at
least going forward if not i hope you
enjoy speaking one of the soviet
languages
i think that it's not so sweet sweden
and finland you're finished yes
wow
think about this
think about this when i say
811 a billion dollars just last year
that's your tax dollars
picture your tax dollars side by side
with an arrogant norwegian finnish
swedish an arrogant prick talking about
how the united states has this
military-industrial complex look hey you
made your bet hey just you know what
stick with your bet
stick with your bet and i really get
pissed off about this because i lived in
canada for years i was raised from
raising canada french canadian mother
from three to 18 years old left as soon
as i possibly could and i would hear
them brag all the time about well you
know here in canada we uh you know we
have uh socialized healthcare
yeah and your military is uh you know
someone in a prop plane with a shotgun
all right so the reason you're able to
do this is because we haven't made you
the 51st state all right and that
applies to the entire world and you are
talking about trillions of dollars
so you think about the 48 billion just
given to ukraine right now no think
about the 811 billion dollars yeah
that's gone to nato think about the 15
was it is it 15 how many and a half 13
and a half trillion but at that point
you know it's just a rounding error
think of the 13 and a half trillion
dollars
that the american taxpayer has footed
for arrogant european nordic pricks
who get to demand when it's convenient
for them that we protect them but in the
preceding decades [ __ ] about how
they're being protected no yeah no
worth you know what it is it's the three
little pigs it's the three little pigs
in finland and sweden you're the one who
built your house out of straw
no i think you're 100 right you've got
to buy into the game now right we've
been paying this bill forever making
sure that this enemy is put at bay you
can't just sit there and claim oh we're
neutral and you're not neutral when
troops start pouring over your borders
of course my outfit is yeah getting a
little tall that's okay yeah you can't
be neutral and you can't come when
things start getting dicey you can't
come to us and say oh hey now we want
your protection right that's not
possible it's not going to happen it is
going to happen it shouldn't happen and
by the way right now what the president
should do is say hey by the way we've
been overpaying
every single country around here who has
not been paying part of your back pay
goes to us we've been overpaying and by
the way do you know the only time in
history when nations started paying
their fair share in to nato donald trump
donald trump and i have an idea that's
true if these nations don't want to do
it that that's perfectly fine
have fun good it should be funneled
right through us and into the hands of
the ukraine yes well you know we'll turn
it right around yeah don't worry we
won't keep it they are beyond reproach
yes unbelievable it will go into the
wrong hands so people hear about this
and go oh yes
this is the kind of issue that most
people don't they don't really think
about they don't 13 trillion dollars
it's insane 13 trillion dollars there we
don't have a problem with them when we
have a problem with the pentagon saying
they're going to perform uh they're
still going to perform abortions of
course but we don't have a problem with
having an effective military we have a
problem with bureaucracy we have a
problem with red tape and we have a
problem with providing military aid to
everybody else in the world
that's the issue i think the united
states should have a strong military do
we need nato
hey let me tell you why we don't need
nato okay
we don't need oil
from the middle east anyway uh we don't
need wheat
from ukraine or russia we don't need to
have access to the pipelines we we don't
need anything from over there we could
be entirely self-sustaining we are
america's bread bass we are the world's
bread basket
and we have more oil than we would know
what to do with by the way if we just
allowed our own we could be in an
entirely self-sustaining country the
rest of the world could turn into an
acme cartoon-like crisp post-firecracker
and we would be fine you all exist
by the grace and the mercy of the united
states we would have been better off if
former vice president biden walked up to
the summit and said yeah yeah i hear
that uh you know sweden and finland
really want to
appropriate response and america's bread
basket is what they call my hips yes
oh geez
what they used to call ellen pages yeah
hey now they're just called the hips
yeah they're just brittle yeah you see
the umbrella academy the new season's
out they devote an entire episode to uh
that person no i want to not kill myself
yeah i didn't even know that show
existed but i don't want to watch it
just based on the name yeah umbrella
academy how much is there to learn what
is simple it can be a push umbrella or
if you're really you know fan if you
have the money one of the button ones
well there's all kinds of umbrellas is
this about uh hey speaking of umbrellas
for turning you know you could use an
umbrella uh whoever's operating the zoom
camera for jeffrey toobin right now on
cnn look hey why don't you trust your
institutions because a serial
masturbator is on there right now how
about that because he has dirt on
everyone who works there yeah that's the
only legal mind that they could possibly
get to apply for the job did they
officially get rid of uh candy ass brian
stelter i don't know i have seen neither
hide nor hair and it's a lot of hide to
miss yeah i know i haven't seen either i
don't know what happened i have heard a
couple of
i've heard
a couple of hooks the banjos from
deliverance off in the distance so i
think he's around here so i got an email
applying for a job i'm just assuming
it's him oh my god
i will pay him so much money if he comes
to work here yeah at least
30 grand yes
speaking of uh
rotund amoebas uh you know uh big hero 6
i actually like that movie i guess
there's a new i like the first one yeah
i guess there's a show coming out now oh
good did you guys know this so there's
some leaked footage
of uh you know baymax is the robot for
people who don't know
um
now is out there shopping for this is
leaked footage so forgive the quality
shopping for tampons here you go okay
excuse me which of these products would
you recommend
none oh she just balls him up and crams
them yeah
these are the tampons i usually use
thank you i prefer pads they're more
comfortable for me watch this i always
get the ones with wings thank you get
unscented and bleach free if you can
thank you mr incredible i love these i
think these might be easier if it's our
first period these are really
environmentally friendly oh wow that's
someone you want to have a party with
these are really environmentally just
punches are off frame we're all
disgusting we are all degenerates did
you notice that that the guy like it
didn't say hey i buy these from my wife
no i said i like using the ones with
wings maybe because you need it to cup
your balls sir
[Laughter]
i didn't know that that could have a
period no guys we're all i didn't know
we're all confused we're all misfits
what about a
boat that has his period
hmm
yeah it's just a cartoon car or a squid
gun that only shoots menstruation
is it leaking oil
no
it's my monthly
oil change can we play this again play
it one more time and just
do you guys understand that the people
making these things hate you are you
getting it yet are you getting it yet do
you really think your kid your
six-year-old kid needs to see
a man talking about his preferences for
for pads with with wings and optional uh
sliding doors for crying out loud do you
really think that
you mean the michelin tire man's trans
cousin yes
let's just see this let's watch this
again
[Music]
excuse me which of these products would
you recommend
oh um for what wow
look at her
i usually use thank you carrots and
bananas they're more comfortable for me
thank you i always get the ones with
wings thank you get unscented and bleach
free if you can thank you yo my daughter
loves these might be easier if it's our
first period these are really
environmentally friendly bleach free
hey it's bleach filled do you remember
when we were young and you guys can
comment below
because i i sometimes people disagree
with me where my parents taught me about
sex really young yeah they taught me
about sex where babies came from because
they didn't want me being lied to
but there was a time in this country
where we taught young girls about how
their bodies worked you know as far as
the intricacies as far as their periods
we taught young boys so while the girls
were off you know learning about their
periods we were learning why boners were
a thing and having a lot of fun
laughing really hard yes i've got one
right now
flipping them and flipping the m m trick
yeah right yes the old fun for the whole
thing i'm gluing them to it like hunter
biden yes i love it
ages six and up
but we didn't learn about girls periods
in depth you know what we learned that
they had a monthly cycle okay and women
are different they have a vagina boys
have i learned that
i didn't learn about their tampons and
their pads because i didn't need to as a
boy it wouldn't be appropriate for the
same reason that i don't think uh my
cousin who was a girl was taught about
my rigid phallus upon looking at my
she-hulk superhero cards
for hours that's true oh that's being
conservative
we started measuring in days they came
back i looked like castaway
i've made fire that's not fire
that's just rug burn
now that feels like fire
all right
so the footage comes from what the new
series baymax in uh six episodes he
helps people with physical ailments
while also getting them over emotional
hurdles is what they're saying i believe
in the show is going to be called uh big
zero dicks yes oh geez yes there's a lot
of these i think there's um like uh well
they're releasing chip and dale's rectum
rangers
i also there's beastie and the bees
there's yep they're releasing
cinderfella 101 disgustings uh eladic
lady was a [ __ ] yes lady was a [ __ ]
well that's just i mean that doesn't
seem it's not as much of a gender that
is horrible but there's a yeah there's a
few of them there's the i mean there's
just the gay lion king which just seems
like it's on the nose yeah that seems
very uh
very well it's also that we was lying
kang yes yes
i just can't wait to be gay
everybody's saying suck this [ __ ]
everybody saying touch that of course uh
what ryan's rental new ryan reynolds has
a new one i believe called it's uh just
called uh free bleed guy yes ah yeah
don't forget transylvania iv yeah
didn't have to
yeah there's also uh all [ __ ] don't go
to heaven ah no that's true
big one
yeah and a remake on chopped i know it
must be a cooking show but yes
yeah all dog all dongs go to and it just
isn't heaven no
it's different
oh they've ruined disney little merman
honey i cut the you know you can just
fill in the blank yeah yeah honey i
transitioned the kids yeah
yeah honey i blew up the fake phallus
honey i brutally molested the kids yes
honey i broke it again yes
parent whether it's uh the parent trap
is just or freaky friday's just they're
just the exact same it's just no one
even bats an eye like oh yeah of course
you're cindy yeah this is but i'm vince
vaughn no sir whatever who cares yeah
the friday's not freaky at all no they
both identified as different things yeah
that's the electric shack
yeah sure yeah you identified as a
six-year-old girl yeah good good it's
just a remake of friday yeah yeah that's
all it is damn
i just can't believe deebo it's a woman
yes
you just got knocked up
girls in the hood yeah
my used to be girl
he doesn't get doesn't get taken out by
bees he gets taken out by a urethra
container the one where he pees out of a
bunch of yeah different holes
you pee out of all the other holes
that's so terrible how would you plan
for aiming that's just impractical
just a lie elijah wood on the treehouse
reaching for a penis that isn't there
anyone who saw the good son you
appreciate that yes
[Laughter]
the god used to be father
[Laughter]
go ahead and sit down in my chair put on
a towel i'm a squirter the lost former
boys
[Laughter]
wonder they thou shall not
bleed
cry little sister i mean brother
thou shalt not bleed
come come to your z
unbelievable oh my gosh this is where we
are they are targeting your kids they
don't care and by the way really quickly
before we go this is why it's a
wonderful thing that in arizona we're
now talking about a school choice bill
yeah so uh we have this it's house bill
two eight five three and what does that
do it expands the state voucher program
to all uh kindergarten through um k-12
students okay so this is something i've
talked about for and i really really do
want and by the way share the show if
you can hit the like button
uh
especially as it relates to the jordan
peterson issue
but i really am curious because i have
put this call out so many times on this
issue and i have never gotten anything
close
close to resembling a a a coaching
argument so
school vouchers just to be clear what
does that mean it means that the money
rather than going to a school is
attached to the student so in arizona uh
what this means right now is and i'll
read a quote here more than six thousand
dollars to each student for education
expenses including private school
tuition curricular materials what does
this mean this means rather than saying
for example uh i don't know what the
average per pupil spending is in the
country right now it's is it somewhere
like 12 13 000
uh it changes from year to year and uh
they averaged out this is the average
per people spending okay then rather
than saying this is the average per
pupil spending and you go to this school
period with no choice it's we're going
to attach and i think we should attach
the full amount if we attach the amount
but we're going to attach a certain
amount of that money to the student so
rather than forcing the student to go to
a school in their district
we give them the credit and they can go
to any school they want and allow the
schools to ah
compete for their dollar now here's
another reason that i don't understand
why this isn't done in the states it's
one thing one of the very few things
that we get right in canada
where i lived i should have gone to
chamblee high school i was allowed to go
to centennial regional high school which
was significantly further i had friends
who lived in the street who went to
mcdonald cartier high school which was
even further as long as you were willing
to drive
you were allowed to go to multiple
schools and people say well what happens
if people just started going to the
better school they got bigger and they
got more money
[Music]
it's almost like they grew so what is
the argument against this i've never
heard a valid argument against school
vouchers the closest i've heard is it's
racist because you know then black kids
won't be able to go to uh better schools
outside of the area okay okay okay okay
let's assume that the shitty schools
that are there now will still be there
but maybe they have a chance in other
words
right now they're forced to go to a bad
school period there's no
there is no hope at least there's hope i
mean if the kid can take a bus if the
kid has parents who can drive him if the
kid can ride his bike right now there
are zero options and you're opening it
up to at least
some options with a voucher attach it to
the student don't just give it to the
teachers union please if anyone has a
valid argument against this
anyone i've never heard it there isn't
one that's why you haven't never heard
maybe there is maybe there is i want to
hear this because this is one of those
issues when i try and research the
counterpoints yeah i can't find any no i
knew a lot of kids from very rough
neighborhoods though that ended up going
to
like one of the high schools i went to
that was in a better neighborhood though
just because they knew some like their
sister lived in the area yeah right
rather than they have to break the law
to do it yeah but they got a better
education
no exactly yeah
so make it so that they don't have to
trick the system yeah what's wrong with
that no i don't i've never i and it's
really really tough we were going to do
one well to get a better education and
there's room for you in the school it's
the problem yeah i mean that's just my
opinion like steven said if there's a
lot of people that want to go to your
school like any business you're like
okay well we have more demand than we
have supply and so let's increase the
supply and bring better teachers better
facilities so we can have more people
by the way it's pay as you go because
like oh we can't we we're full the good
news is more people want to get into
this school and there's money attached
to them so we know we're gonna have the
money to expect there is no issue
and we i think we even need to change my
mind or something similar to it about
school choice and it was we just didn't
we didn't end up running it because
every person who thought they were
against it they go oh wait that's what a
voucher
yeah okay that makes sense
that was it we didn't have a single one
who could argue this is with professors
by the way it wasn't even on a campus i
know the counter the counterpoint to
charter schools is that they don't
perform any better than public schools
and if you if you try to torture the
data long enough that'll be true but if
you look at thomas soule's book where he
actually compared charter schools right
that were located in the same building
as public schools because they had
excess space in new york city they
way outperformed the students in the
same building it's the most apples to
apples comparison you can possibly but
here's the thing this doesn't even apply
to charter schools no i know in other
words you can take it to charter schools
or to public schools you can take it
wherever you want that money is yours to
do as you will well that's the thing
funding going anywhere other than to
public schools and the teachers there
they're saying charter schools was step
one this is step three of that well in
other words in other words if someone
lives in a district and the public
school that they want to go to that
happens to be better we know that in
texas right your property values change
dramatically based on the public school
district so it's oh it happens to be 500
yards past where you're actually legally
allowed to attend that school this
removes that and says well instead of
just your money going to the school that
sucks you can take the money to that
school that's only 500 yards further
even if it's a public school so yeah it
allows public schools to compete it
allows charter schools private schools
to enter into the mix yep
it's perfect wouldn't it help too if you
had high schools that were a little bit
you know i understand freshman sophomore
year when you're sort of taking
the the more basic classes that you have
to have right but by the time you're a
junior and senior especially in america
you're pregnant well yeah well you're
very proud and especially with these
other kids coming in from the hood now
you got mixed babies
no i uh
joking it's a joke media matters
uh but
uh realistically like you have why don't
you have these different programs set up
at different schools that allow for
other people's interests if it's say
drama film uh working on cars nursing
whatever like why why not cater to that
already in high school so you can pivot
to that correct market of college
private schools and charter schools do
that now in other words they they have
more sort of what would be considered
elective courses you have your
fundamentals and they'll have other
courses that might be more if a student
might have a higher aptitude for it
right yeah public schools can't do that
because they suck
yeah well i think that's terrible i
didn't know that yeah that's i think
that's a really good idea yep just to
test the money in the kitchen instead of
giving the money to the school public
school this yeah so did i yeah instead
of my dad really sort of my dad in inner
city detroit yeah yeah no no you were
not in there no i wasn't in the inner
city no no no no no no you know my dad i
know bob's crowder's hardcore i was a
mile over from
your dad
and boy a mile makes a difference
[Laughter]
oh my gosh my my aunt stopped going i
think she got like she just didn't go to
her graduation ceremony because the girl
got shot in the face well
you know i talked to your aunt about
that yeah oh yeah just shot in the face
yeah it was like uh-huh all right how
many are you like and that was like the
third time mail me the diploma yeah you
get a diploma and a slug so i just don't
see any argument against it i just i
know i'm sounding repetitive but please
anyone i want to hear it and if there's
an expert out there who can actually
educate me on this
be glad to have this person on the show
not a twitter egg who says you suck
someone who was an actual expert you
know uh uh
like a researcher like that heather uh
cox with that gift that we talked about
yesterday yeah yeah no gifts but we are
going to have to go to a mug club here
and take your costumes the winner this
is the last day of cultural
appropriation month it's the last show
before we go on break that we'll still
have some videos coming in uh and you
can follow me on social loud
earthquaker.com
tour dates
rebels with a cause comedy tour me and
dave kicks off september 16th in arizona
just expanded that theater so now there
are more seats available houston
september 17th so that's friday and
saturday the smart financial center at
uh sugarfoot and uh dave is going to be
what's the date you're in columbus uh
1516 columbus ohio over july
and then the funny bone tours which
omaha nebraska date in ohio columbus
check me out davelanda.com we love you
youtube we sorry i misspoke youtube i
despise you piss off
oh